oh playing the other eric
we played recently actually
fellow eric
we used to be roommates too
he beat me recently so it's time for
maybe hopefully revenge
let's see his prep
i remember our last game yeah he played
some
funny line
last game he played bishop g4 before i
played knight of three
yeah we played in arena kings where
like i was trying to dirty flag him but
he like
checkmated me with a few seconds left
this is different because there's
increments
i'm gonna play a solid line bishop d6 i
just take it
i think a4
a rookie one first a4 comes eventually
queen a4
i mean
there's like a couple i used to
eventually
london players maybe trade off lights
for bishops the vegans are and
crossfitters are around that group out
and uh
i truly am like very positional very
weary
of this subculture
you also get the rock climbers the
colorado folk
as well
it's tough it's really tough for guys
like me
weebs london players
climbing fanatics vegans crossfitters
i'm gonna play uh fd2 i'm harder and
harder
i'm gonna go here one idea i don't mind
this
he's considering whether to take the
queen
yeah maybe i should not have a lot of
that
let me go here
i mean knight
c55 here
65 hangs upon
it doesn't
actually don't know
let's try it i would say the point is if
it takes take off
ah there's knight p3 though
oh wait it takes takes takes i take the
rook
hitting the queen
okay that's fortunate
the point is to eventually play b5
i'm also attacking this four times
and of course b2 is a little bit tender
look we're gonna be maybe knight a6
let's play b4
yeah i'm definitely uh
making some strangers this is exactly
what
i try and achieve from this opening
smiley face pawns
let's see i'm just like i'm looking at
the position
and my brain is not registering anything
do you guys ever have that
like
i'm not producing anything
queen g3 idea
really
i'm taking d5
the knight of three i taken my head i'd
like to think i'm producing something
but
in actuality i'm not
under pressure though
f4 doesn't work
[Music]
two
[Music]
and this move
how does f5 comes
i think it's okay
g3
some c4 idea
oh no
have this move
yeah four is coming i have the same
tackle idea
my defense
eric's playing well here
definitely playing well
okay
i can't play that
what's with my speed
wait what
oh tricky
i just blender piece
i did why am i blundering pieces
let's go okay
got really low on turn got me there he
was he was leading that
oh that was a
workout okay
that's revenge for last time
yeah someone was asking earlier my
highest heart rate has been on stream
that may have broken their record
the previous time was when i played the
karu
it got to like 169.